sarà una buonissima colazione bentornati
a rincalzo nice
oggi il nuovissimo video speciale che ci
avete richiesto e in tantissimi e ce le
giocheremo ascheri teacher nella vita
reale se non avete visto il nostro
gameplay in cui giochiamo scheri di ter
bilancio poi 4 quadratini finali
il video che vi potete andare a vedere
camente io dovrò fare una serie di
scherzi alla maestra spaventosa scheri
teacher nel frattempo berlino è salito
là sopra vabbè comunque praticamente
devo fare una serie di scherzi ascheri
teacher ma non devo essere beccata vengo
preso proprio di tre volte ho perso la
solenne sarà divertentissimo
se volete vedere una seconda parte
lasciate un mi piace a questo video e se
questo video raggiunge il 20 mila mi
piace ci sarà anche la seconda parte in
cui li faremo altri perfetti anzi
consigliateci pure nei commenti quali
altri scherzetti potrei fare ascheri
teaser ma ora andiamo subito a vedere
dov'è
[Musica]
prima scherzo che dovevo fare e mentre
per farle nella sua ciotola con il latte
di cereali quindi ora scendiamo vediamo
dove lanciato lo combatte i cereali e
cerchiamo il sale ovviamente non
dobbiamo essere freddo benvenuto tanti
rumori come sempre
[Applauso]
no che ritirarmi ha già presa una volta
guardate calcio c'è il piatto devo
mettere il sale però prima dovuto levare
il sale cerchiamolo assieme berlino
aiutami sommare serre come il tuo fiuto
infallibile dice che di qua
[Musica]
ok non sento più la maestra scrittice
quindi forse via libera allora verso
latte con i cereali farà una buonissima
colazione non mi nascondo però adesso
berlino turci nascondiamo noi andiamo
nascondersi porterà dietro di sul divano
[Musica]
capiamo
sì abbiamo superato il primo livello ora
siamo al secondo livello vediamo quanti
ribelli consecutivi riusciamo a fare
allora per il secondo livello
se uno scherzetto allora dove non messa
era in qualcuno di questi qua
non ci faranno male
guarino che cos'è allora deve smetterla
e questa frase la stessa più epico di
sempre dove potrei metterla stavo
pensando potrei metterla nel letto
mentre dorme pure
nelle scale oppure nella sedia
così quando va a sedere si interrompe
per lì ho pensato che è ancora più
divertente se lo metto compagno cabine
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ti io sto è mancato poco
berlino lì quindi forse lei mi sta
dicendo che c'è a camerino che bravo
mourinho l'ha mandato via g
merlino starda da mio padre che l'ha
mandata via ok ora approfittiamo del
momento di distrazione
aspettando che casa in bagno ma non so
quanto dovrà andare in qua
[Musica]
beh
ci siamo stati in trentino nuovamente
abbiamo solo una possibilità però
abbiamo superato anche secondo livello e
spazio troppo divertente
poi alla fine del video votate con il
sondaggio quale lo scherzo che vi state
troppo divertente
ora passiamo al terzo scherzo vediamo se
riusciamo a fare anche questo così
passiamo al quarto livello
allora ho pensato a una cosa per il
terzo sterzo nei cassetti parte in mezzo
agli ingredienti time l'aveva nascosto
ma non mi ricordo top e allora qua ho
tutte le mie colle ma se qualcosa in più
controllando che cos'è allora sembra uno
scarafaggio vero ma ovviamente non lo è
se non sbaglio funziona che c'è cammina
vediamo se funziona ancora funzionante e
merlino vuole subito andare a mangiarlo
ma no no berlino non si mangia questo
guarda ti penso che sia perché penso che
si spaventerà perché fa un rumore strano
e il cammino merlino non è un gioco per
te comunque devo ancora the sitter però
dove metterlo per lo spavento sul
cuscino o sul tavolino così lei magari
si sveglia e vede subito
l'insetto che va verso di lei possiamo
fare una prova possiamo metterlo nel
cuscino vediamo se cammina se non
cammina lo mettiamo nel comodino a
fianco al letto ma dobbiamo prima
aspettare che si addormenti altrimenti
mi becker ha subito
[Musica]
non va bene metto non dicono si muovono
ci vuole una superficie piatta
[Musica]
no
troppo divertente su scherzo purtroppo
però che ri tizio che mi ha preso per la
terza volta quindi non posso andare
avanti con gli altri livelli
ma se questo video raggiunge i 20 mila
mi piace si saranno altri scherzi
consigliate fra tutti gli scherzi da
farle dei commenti
e stato un trucco di pertanto se siamo
divertiti entrambi tantissimo abbiamo
riso stack
mi raccomando lasciate un bel mi piace e
votate con il sondaggio qual è lo
scherzo che vi ha divertito di più
secondo me il più divertente è stato
quello della racchetta quello con il
latte è stato divertentissimo e comunque
ora vi lasciamo un calco altre case
dimessa qwiki car per vedere i nostri
altri video cliccate su quella che
preferite e buona visione